[Music]
okay so this is my review of the first
three episodes that dropped on Apple
Plus today of truth be told starring
Octavia Spencer as poppy and Erin Paul
as Warren cave this is one of the series
on Apple TV plus that was most excited
for and I got worried a bit when I saw
that the showrunner and main writer of
it was just a writer and producer on
shows like The Good Wife it was an
interesting pick and I was like all
right let's see what's what she's got
here what's she gonna bring to the table
that is nichelle tramble Spellman and
then you see quickly in episode one
where there's writing gets a little
ridiculous the first red flag for me was
the scene where Octavia Spencer is going
to see Lisbeth Perkins the actress who
plays warren caves mom and she drops her
garbage bag of groceries and you see
it's all these empty boxes of Trader
Joe's which is just insane product
placement that they have Octavia Spencer
pick it up once zooms in on it then
randomly in the scene picks another one
up zooms in on it and to justify that
they connect it as oh you my mom had
breast cancer and she had this same diet
so I know you have breast cancer that is
a crazy assumption just to say to
somebody and to put that together like
oh that's the breast cancer diet is
Trader Joe's frozen meals like what the
hell so that was just red flag number
one also they're just playing pop songs
here there's not really a score to it
it's just random music being thrown in
and out and moments where you thought it
would shine where Erin Paul is with
Octavia Spencer you got two great actors
together the script does not let them
there's this weird little monologue Erin
Paul has of eenie meenie miney moe and
his character who's been in jail this
long has amazing dental cares teeth
could not be shinier which is one of
those things that frustrates me and
shows especially when you're playing
some one of those to be a prisoner at
come on you got to make him look a
little more the part here and just the
way they revealed his nine
see tattoo was just so on the nose with
like pausing and him rolling his sleeve
up like look you know it's just really
cringey and just some more weird writing
where Elizabeth Perkins the mother here
says to poppy Oh justifying her son in
prison becoming a Nazi and talking about
a monster she compares it to the first
time she had a cigarette how was that
anyway the same and then really where it
gets weird is when we meet Poppy's
husband who enters the house like some
kind of sitcom entrance where he just
wears a suit in his own home and you'll
see this through the first year episodes
I guess they don't have any comfortable
clothing there there's even points where
she comes home to him just sitting on
the couch in a tie I don't know who does
that and he acts like he's a stranger in
his own house which is odd and he's also
the same man who goes to a biker bar in
a suit and there's no chemistry even
though they're husband and wife between
these two at all and then we get
flashbacks here of Aaron Paul who's this
kid who's convicted of this murder and
the kid doesn't look anything like Aaron
Paul come on casting Department that's
on you like you're gonna cast the kid
I'm sure there's tons I look like Aaron
Paul I don't think that's a hard one to
pull off in it does look anything like
him and the weirdest thing was his story
about how he was hunting for the drugs
in the house where the murder took place
and he goes break into the house and
then roll under the beds of the two
girls at night that was so strange and
then it ends just with another not
making sense line to me where papi says
to Aaron Paul here say anything racist
you will be in jail for life why would
you say that I mean you just had this
huge flash of guilt on yourself you
realize you've ruined this man's life
and you're trying to get him out of
there and then but wait a minute if
you're any bit racist to me it's over
like I don't care if you are someone
who's innocent doesn't deserve prison I
basically ruined your life no if you say
something racist your app come on
and I know I'm being really hard right
now but again I'm trying to fairly
review it and if I'm looking at the
positives it's the acting but again it's
hampered by the writing and the writing
is always so important for this reason
and I was really hyped for the show and
I think I had so much potential you're
so it's so frustrating to see some of
this writing that's going on here and
it's why am i laughing at the show I
don't want to be but I have to be honest
here so let's jump it up so to thinking
maybe we'll get better and it just gets
silly like Aaron Paul is on the phone
my mom has cancer and then the jail guy
goes Oh your mom has cancer then they
get he slams the phone into him and get
a fight over it's like oh my god
rolling eyes city again then it just you
realize this show is like CBS quality
9:00 p.m. on a Tuesday night quality
kind of thing right after Hawaii five-o
and that's what's frustrating because
with Apple TV plus you want it to be
more like HBO if that's what they're
going for ceman that you could sell is
only a couple shows on our service with
their premium this is not it oh and then
the funniest scene yet is obviously you
see that there's these twin sisters and
bros plays by Lizzy Caplan and one's
just a blonde version of herself and
she's like undercover thing going out
for a bit where she's got this British
accent which is just ridiculous and
weird because she doesn't go back to it
and they're talking about Josie in the
car
her and her mom and they get into this
car accident when Josie calls and Susan
the mom dies because of this iPhone so
that is terrible plugging of an iPhone
for Apple if you want to throw so much
product placement for Apple products in
shows fine I get it your Apple Plus but
you're not even realizing you're showing
hey you know if you look at our device
giving you text or call you might get in
a car accident just hysterically silly
scene oh and the best is the
brown-haired version of Lizzy Caplan
can't find her mom's iPhone after cuz
Mekhi Phifer took it so I guess the Find
My iPhone feature doesn't work on these
phones either again not looking good for
your own products and the best line of
the show so far is Lizzy Caplan says to
her husband I'm not a vase I'm not gonna
shatter that's a moment like I'm out
like come on really who talks like that
I promise you that statement has never
been said in the history of just life in
world and human interaction and then
when the twins finally talk to each
other on the phone the best part is when
Josie says it's hard to breathe without
you and it seems like they're big enough
but then she's like but I'm never coming
home you terrify me click like what how
can you say that thing that you're
basically meaning you need each other's
twins and you just know but you're scary
goodbye like that quickly like I don't
even know oh and then then the episode
Aaron Paul gets stabbed so no but so
three you find out more and more that
Aaron Paul's father the chief of police
basically threw his summit under the bus
here and he's clear
skeletons and all of this actor Bret :
when you see him in shows now he's
almost being overused he's in movies
like The Joker where every time you see
his character you know something's up
with him he's got to be bad but casting
wise hey it looks like Mekhi Phifer is
having fun he's doing a good job so
there's a positive good to see him back
out there and then just this over
exaggeration of these cartoon as
characters like just a security girl
working at the prison she's really
intense - Octavia Spencer her niece
she's like your white boy got shanked
like white oh and then we get the line
of the century in this episode where
poppy and her husband get in a fight and
he says there is out there
and there is in here and poppy says back
but that is my in here and we can fight
anywhere in this house but there so
follow the bouncing ball when you're
seeing lines like this it really feels
like dr. Seuss so if someone could
translate what all that means I'd love
to know and he just realizes episode
this side story of Josie twin thing
going on is just terrible it is one of
the most in least interesting plots I've
ever seen the show oh and then you don't
think you get worse we see now the
sister gets arrested at the bar and we
see this quick transformation where they
strip her of everything she's put in
this jail cell and then quickly is
bailed out the next scene and they give
her the line when she sees her dad and
says daddy my hair oh my god and then
the dad jokes Octavia Spencer I was like
all right who is on set here can someone
just say something to fix this like I
can't believe I couldn't believe what I
was watching and then to get you really
excited so for it ends with Aaron Paul
saying he's gonna give everyone in the
jail a show cuz he's gonna get back the
man who stabbed him great who cares
so obviously you could tell I hate this
it's abysmal I try to look for anything
positive in this and it's really hard
again Octavia Spencer and Paul are
always great actors but when a script is
so bad there's only so much you can do
it sounds like I'm being a huge jerk
right now and I respect everyone who
works in the field and writers creators
and that goes with the creator here too
I just think it's something that was a
lot to take on from not the greatest
resume yet and at least get some help
and just double-check triple-check make
sure you're given the best product
possible
didn't feel like it felt like Apple TV
plus was shipping us so I want to be a
voice when that is happening and calling
it out and this feels like that case
completely it's so lazy it's a mess so
I'm giving this one a three for the
first three episode as a whole let me
know what you thought of it down below
maybe you really liked it maybe Greasley
disagree me let me know I'd love to hear
your thoughts please make sure to
subscribe to my channel I'm reviewing a
bunch of shows the moment Watchmen
servant and His Dark Materials you don't
want to miss any of those and I also do
celebrity interviews so you want to
check those out and please follow me at
Steve Varley 1 on Twitter and for more
of me and I'll see you next time